why did you why did you start dancing
i started dancing because i wanted to be
a performer
like i love you know i always like like
loved playing the violin
i kind of lost my passion for it along
the way somewhere and
um i started to be like i need to find
my voice in the violin
not just like you know i'd always just
like looked at sheet music and just
regurgitated exactly what i was told to
play the way they told me to play it
like every
articulation is dictated through some
sort of a mark on the page
and i just lost the passion through that
i think it wasn't for me
and so once i discovered like i want to
figure out how i can be the voice not
the violin
um it made me excited about writing and
then the kind of music i was writing i
was like if i
ever want to perform something like this
kind of music i can't just
stand there i was like it doesn't feel
right to me it doesn't look right
and i was like as a person who loves
entertainment i was like
i wouldn't want to sit through a show
where someone would be standing there
and playing
this song it wouldn't fit to me so i was
like well i gotta make it visual i gotta
add some energy somehow so pretty much
just came from like what would i as a
consumer want to see if i heard this
music and i was like i'd want to see the
violinist dancing
what i think is cool is that what i'm
hearing
is that you were always envisioning
yourself alone on the stage
people were coming to see you you were
not
part of something you were not a
an aspect or in like even with anybody
or anything
it was you on the stage alone and i
think that's like
very confident and cool it's you know
funny looking back at it
i don't know where i got that tenacity
to be like
i know that i can sell out shows by
myself
as a violinist for an hour and a half
set i know i can do it you know like
here i was a girl that had no
following like i'm not sure where that
tenacity came from
but i was so determined and um my mom
even says she's like
i knew you would succeed because i just
like because you believed it so strongly
she's like of course i was worried as a
mother watching you go on this journey
but she's like but
i knew you'd make it like i feel like i
willed my career into existence i say
that often i just believed it so
strongly and
you know wouldn't stop trying new things
until
i figured out something that worked
thoughts become things
i 100 believe uh you you
dream big have a vision but the magic
sauce
that i always say is that you actually
believe it yes if you you can think all
kinds of stuff and it doesn't mean that
you know you might not get somewhere
with oh i want to play the violin
someday and then all of a sudden it kind
of leads to like
you know juilliard or whatever it ends
up being you know
but it's the belief in the vision that
actually
anchors it absolutely well because if
you know i look back
i think to myself how hard like anyone
has to work like how hard i had to work
to get to where i'm at today and
like i said anybody that's like chasing
dreams you have to work your tail off
and if you don't believe that especially
in the beginning
those thankless things you're doing that
aren't getting any traction if you don't
believe genuinely that they are steps
towards something
you know and if you're like i actually
don't believe i can do this there's no
way you're gonna keep
doing that thankless journey that's hard
and lonely
and you know and it feels kind of blind
sometimes and if you don't believe you
can do it there's no way
you're gonna keep after it i always call
that blind faith like
there was a lot of reasons why i didn't
feel like i was
why i shouldn't have made it in racing
except all i can say
is that i just had blind faith and i
believed that it was gonna work
yeah like no damn reason like i'm 19
years old coming back from england with
a ged
and no job for like basically two years
and like no reason and then a couple of
years after that i'm driving an indy car
and almost won the indy 500. like
there's no good reason
why it worked out there's but there's
got there's
it i get that but tell me about your
parents
what were they like and was one of them
a really big dreamer
or uh supported you in a way that felt
um empowering did they lead by example
yes my parents both were so supportive
i'm sure that played a huge role in my
belief in myself
is because i you know i knew that they
were my biggest fans you know and they
they would show up continuously to
whatever it was that i
was excited about and dreaming about um
you know they were always there
and i remember i think one of the most
impactful
things from my childhood is that my dad
um
he was a great storyteller and he was a
writer like he actually wanted to be
like a film writer right screenplays and
he had like these different screenplays
that he had written
and he would read them to me as like
well bedtime stories or
he would also tell us tales from his own
life and sometimes i couldn't tell
which were the tales from his own
adventures and which were
the made-up stories he would almost like
sometimes melt the two together
and so it was just such a fun world to
grow up in
where these were stories he had created
somehow in his life and i remember from
a really early age
saying dad i want to live a life like
you
i want to travel to places i want to
meet people i want to do
things um and he said you will you will
you know and just that sense that he had
lived a life of adventure
not because he succeeded at all of his
dreams he actually never became that
famous
screenplay writer that he wanted to be
but boy he went for it
and he he lived a life of adventure
because he tried
and he loved his life you know he had a
family and he
you know he ended up being a teacher and
he loved being a teacher but also
the great stories came from the fact
that he tried and so it kind of taught
me that there's no shame
in going after what you want in life and
you know
because whether you end up at the goal
you imagined or not you will live
a colorful life and go places and meet
people and see things and have stories
um and i wanted more than anything so
it's almost kind of like he taught me
the value of
the journey and that's what i was
actually seeking for
you